Ừ
mình vẫn chưa chuẩn bị à gọi nh nào chưa
đăng cái bài lên là tạo cái cá hút.
Chắc là để mình làm luôn được không nhỉ?
Tận
các thứ ở đây.
Ừ.
Thread hay thông báo nhỉ? Thread để cho
mọi người có thể bình luận được nhá.
À ca hút
tham gia.
Mọi người góp ý giúp mình.
nhé. Đây
ví dụ là
ấ
đây
bộ câu hỏi
giải thưởng
định là top 3
Tôi để ở góc này nhá.
Các bạn không nghe được cứ bảo mình nhá.
Ừ.
thời gian
à
thêm cho anh con boss để
tạo khung
này nhé.
không gọi nh trong tuần này chắc là mọi
người vẫn kịp nhỉ đúng không?
Bây giờ mới nhế thứ ba mà thì ví dụ thứ
bảy chủ nhật chẳng hạn. Thế đấy. Ờ
theo là cho mọi người đọc qua cái này
nữa. Tôi tôi định là như thế nghĩa là
mình sẽ không chỉ mỗi người học, mình sẽ
ngồi nói chuyện và chia sẻ kiểu giao
lưu, chia sẻ quan điểm về rất nhiều cái.
Và
nói chung là hồi trước tôi từng thích
xem các streamer ấy thì thật ra là ngồi
nghe họ nói
là nhiều hơn so với việc là xem cái a
thứ mà họ làm. Tức là sao? Ví dụ giả sử
là các ông xem thưa các streamer nổi,
mấy ông cũng thấy thế mà sự là ờ tôi xem
của hôm trước có xem cả anh Độ này, cả
anh Pu Piu này, cả
gì nhỉ?
Hồi trước có JV Everm nhưng mà cái đấy
hiển nhiên là họ chỉ làm thuần về nội
dung rồi. Nhưng mà đấy nghĩa là ông hiểu
tôi không? Nghĩa lúc đầu là họ thể xuất
thân là kiểu là một streamer về game
nhưng mà rõ ràng là về sau các ông nghe
thấy kiểu họ sẽ nổi về việc là
chia sẻ cái quan điểm và họ sẽ nói là
nhiều. Hôm đấy thì là mình không quan
tâm về game mấy nữa, mình còn chơi game
mấy nữa đâu. Đấy thì thôi cũng không hẳn
là kiểu sẽ theo cái phong cách kiểu đấy.
Nhưng ý tôi là kiểu tôi thấy thế là một
cái tương tác nó cũng rất là hay. Nó
không chỉ mỗi việc là tôi làm việc của
tôi xong rồi mấy ông thì ngồi xem những
thứ tôi làm đấy. Bởi vì thực sự thì nếu
mà giả sử ông cùng trong ngành với tôi
đúng không? Thế thì cái việc mà tôi làm
có khi là ông còn ngứa mắt thế kiểu đãi
ông phải cốt theo phong cách kiểu này
đấy. Kiểu thế nhưng mà nếu mà giả sử mà
cũng là người trong nhành với nhau đúng
không? Nhưng mà chúng ta nói chia sẻ
quan điểm với nhau thì nó lại hay. kiểu
dạng là à tôi biết được cái mẹo của ông,
biết được cái
cách tư duy của ông khi mà đi bx các thứ
khi mà gặp vấn đề thì ông xử lý như nào
đấy nghĩa là người trong ngành với nhau.
Đặc biệt là người trong ngành ngành ngi
chung này đúng là chúng ta nói chuyện
nhau rất nhiều nhá. Nhưng mà chúng ta
nói chuyện về những chủ đề khác hay là
chúng ta
thực ra là tôi nghĩ là phải nói chuyện
nhau nhiều nhưng mà ở trong cái không
gian gọi là trong mối quan hệ vòng quan
hệ của mình thôi và nó rất là ít nó rất
là bé vì mình dân tính ra là dân IT mình
không tiếp đi tiếp xúc nhiều nhiều ông
còn hướng nội nữa tôi hồi trước tôi còn
từng thấy là có nhiều ông là kiểu coi đã
từng tâm sự với tôi nhiều tôi không tôi
không nói là là họ kiểu dạng tôi không
biết là họ có người khác để mà nói
chuyện hay không nhưng từng có người
chưa gặp tôi bao giờ nhưng tâm sự rất
nhiều bởi vì họ tôi cảm thấy là họ
ít mối quan hệ ở bên ngoài đấy tôi cảm
thấy thế còn nếu mà họ tin tưởng tôi thì
tốt thôi nhưng mà đấy nghĩa là tôi đã
chia sẻ khá là đủ nhiều để mà họ tin
tưởng để mà họ có thể tâm sự nói chuyện
lạ nên tôi cảm thấy Đấy là một thành
công rồi.
Ơ có người vào này. Xin chúc mừng à nh
xin chào các bạn. Nhưng mà không có ai ở
đây
chat nhưng mà mấy ông vào Discord tôi
không biết được mấy ông vào Discord cha
mấy ông tò mò xem trong đấy có gì. Thôi
đa số là thế. Hồi trước tôi cũng vào tôi
thoát mà.
Đây.
Ok. Chào cháu.
À rồi ken hôm nay lên một bài mới. Cái
này hôm trước của tôi chia sẻ nhưên tôi
chưa kịp đọc.
này là
bài gốc. ở trên hai team community nhưng
là bài này thực ra là cũng từ một ông co
của lá phe đúng không? Đấy chia sẻ
bài này không mang tính giải trí ít
người đọc tương tác kiểu kiểu khả năng
tương tác sẽ thấp đúng không tính ứng
dụng trực tiếp đọc chỉ mở mở mang tượng
góc nhìn và không đọc hết hiểu không tới
định luật linh tinh khá mệt nhưng bài
viết này nó sẽ
chạm được một vấn đề nhầm lẫn phổ biến
khi nói về open AI và AI nói chung.
Đầu tiên chúng ta phải hiểu cần hiểu về
Weat n tôi đang đọc hộ mấy ông nhá.
Nhưng mà tôi thực ra tôi cũng đọc để tự
tôi
cứ cho là tự tôi đọc đi. Đấy tôi cũng
nói biết để mấy ông biết tôi đang đọc
đến đâu.
học Java theo hướng nào vậy ạ? Anh học
Java theo hướng ừ thật ra anh chưa ghi à
anh có ghi rõ trong mô tả không nhỉ?
Ừ hình như là anh còn chưa ghi rõ trong
mô tả này thì phải. Lỗi của tôi.
Ok. Tôi chưa ghi mõ trong một à. Đây để
tôi ghi thêm
bay.
cái playlist thôi. Đợi tôi một tí tôi
sửa lại. Đợi tôi một tí nhá.
Tôi sẽ sửa lại cái mô tả đây.
mấy ông cứ bình luận nhá.
viên PP dễ sang nhưng sợ nó không đủ.
Đây tôi sẽ
ờ tôi sẽ dùng Gini ở đây đi.
Tôi muốn ghi mô tả ngắn gọn về
playlist.
này
từ một dòng trình viên PP dễ sang
tìm hiểu sâu hơn về clean architect
Thực ra tôi đã nói hết rồi. Thực ra dùng
AI để nó xem kiểm tra lại xem nó hợp lý
hay không thôi mà.
Architect viết như này nhỉ? Visa hiện
tại chắc không sao đâu. Ai tex đi đây
kiểu nh không sao tí nó sờ lại mình à
hướng đối tượng
oop và
xử lý chuyên sâu
backend
về các bài toán tối ưu
và thiết kế.
>> Đợi tôi tí. Đợi tí. Đợi tôi tí.
tập trung đào sâu tư duy OOP clean
architect đấy và viết sah tả nhưng mà
quan trọng gì đâu ờ giải quyết Viết bài
toán tối ưu hiệu năng back end
performance và system design.
hả? Có hạn chế à?
Có hạn chế đâu
cha ông lần đầu nói. Đ nó bị kiểu hạn
chế chứ.
động khi chế độ hạn chế được bật. Để xem
video t nào cũng vì tôi đúng không?
một lập trình viên PP lâu năm. Playlist
này không chỉ học sinch
mà là quá trình tôi nghiên cứu sâu về
clean architect thiết kế hướng đối tượng
và tối ưu hóa backend được đấy trông
kiểu hợp lý hơn dành ra vlog đúng không
dạng nhật ký cũng khá là hay nhưng mỗi
tội thì nó có cái từ này tôi không thích
này không chỉ học sin tách này nữa thực
ra làm gì mình cũng học sinh tắc đâu
chuyên nghiệp deep die java
Chuyển đổi tư duy từ PP sang Java. Hệ
thống hóa kiến thức từ về clean
architect OP nâng cao và các kỹ năng các
ui cái này chuyên nghiệp quá tôi không
đế ngưỡng này. Tôi nghĩ là cái này khá
là hay này hoặc cái này hay
nào nhất? Tôi thấy phương án một này hợp
lý đúng không? Phương án hai này thì
cũng khá hay nhưng mà nó sẽ có thêm cái
c như này
không chỉ học sinch mình có học sin tách
không nhỉ? Thứ không có mà đúng không?
Nhưng mà nó sẽ nói giống như kiểu là
ý tôi ấy là
cái khóa này không hề dạy về cách viết
Java nên cái câu mà không chỉ học sinch
giống như là kiểu vẫn sẽ có học tức là
chỉ là vẫn sẽ học Java cơ bản rồi mới
bắt đầu nghiên cứu sâu ông hiểu chưa thì
nó không đúng vì rõ ràng là chúng ta học
có học cơ bản đâu chúng ta có học cách
kiểu Java viết như thế nào vân vân vân.
Cái đấy chắc là không.
Mỗi tội hành trình chuyển mình
thì nó lại không đúng bởi vì rõ ràng tôi
không chuyển mình mà nó sẽ chỉở góc nhìn
thôi.
Ờ
phương án
chỉ đào sâu về tư duy
tư này
mental model này là từ gì gốc dễ các thứ
đấy.
thấy rằng Jini trả lời nhiều lúc kém nên
là thôi tôi không dùng mấy cái này nữa.
Tôi chỉ chơi pro thôi. Mà rõ ràng là cái
từ pro mà đúng không? Thì rõ ràng là
mình phải dùng th chứ mình trả tiền thì
mình có cái này mà đúng không? Tôi cứ
dùng cái này thôi. Nên thành ra vừa nãy
tôi thấy khó chịu cái quả mà lúc mà tôi
dùng chattivity đúng không? Thì nó sẽ nó
sẽ gọi là như nào? Nó sẽ trả lời rất là
nhanh đúng không? Thì rõ ràng nó không
phải grow. Tôi còn đang dùng bản thường
mà không phải bản mất phí. Đấy là tôi
cảm thấy cấm k hỏi thằng Gemini nó trả
lời lâu vãi. Xong mới nhận ra là ừ mình
đang dùng cái chế độ là nó trả lời lâu
mà. Nhưng mà trả lời lâu nhiều lúc tôi
cảm thấy là tôi vẫn không ưng lắm.
Chứ đừng nói là kiểu thà trả lời lâu của
nó ưng nhá. Nên là tôi nghĩ là thực ra
là công ty AI nói chung nó vẫn đang làm
cho mình bị hơi bị rối mấy ông hình dung
không? Kiểu ít ra chat VT còn nó còn làm
mình dễ hiểu nhá. Chứ
mấy thằng khác hiện tại nó cứ làm rối
đến cả mang tiếng Google bây giờ nó làm
mình rối. Hồi trước tôi từng nói là
Google là một cái công ty khiến cho
người dùng rất dễ dùng. Dễ dùng ở đây
giao diện dễ dùng ấy. Kiểu lúc đó chỉ có
một cái thanh tìm kiếm đúng không? Thanh
đấy được ra người ta không hiểu thanh
tìm kiếm. Cứ nhập bừa vào cái gì nó cũng
ra. Nhập vào câu hỏi gì nó cũng sẽ có
thể có một cái đáp án nào đó cho mình.
nhập vào 1 + 1 mấy hay nhập vào à giá
vàng hôm nay hoặc là đổi tiền tệ hoặc
thời tiết hôm nay vân vân n thứ nó sẽ ra
một cái gì phù hợp chưa chắc là nó là
một chỉ cho mình mấy cái trang web mà
đôi khi trả lời đáp án mình luôn đấy thì
rõ ràng là Google từng
kiểu khiến người dùng không phải nghĩ
như thế đấy thì bây giờ Google lại khiến
đi hơi bị
trang ra nó bắt trước với cái thằng khác
đang đi thì thôi mình cũng đi theo. Đấy
lại làm ra cái ứng dụng không
không phải nói là khó dùng bởi vì rõ
ràng là tính ra thì mình vẫn dùng được
chứ tôi nghĩ là nó sẽ không còn là tối
giản hóa cho người dùng nữa. Người dùng
đấy ví dụ tôi đến hình này bây giờ tôi
chẳng biết chọn cái nào. Rõ ràng tôi
muốn nó trả lời nhanh nhưng mà tôi không
muốn nó trả lời kiểu quá thiếu suy nghĩ.
Mà rõ ràng tôi nghĩ là tôi chọn cái này
là phù hợp nhưng mà rõ ràng thanh kinh
nó nghe nó không chất lượng với chữ pro.
Tôi thích Pro đấy. Nhưng pro nó lại chỉ
dành cho toán nâng cao và code đấy ông
ông hiểu ý rồi. Bây giờ rốt cuộc là mình
chọn cái nào đấy mà tôi nghĩ ở cái này
nữa nhá. Giả sử tôi chọn cái này đúng
không? Để mà chat bình thường nhá. Thì
cái này nó vẫn trả lời lâu hơn cái này.
Chắc chắn rồi. Đấy.
Thế thì rõ ràng chẳng lẽ tôi lại bảo con
này kém con chatt chatt rõ ràng tôi thấy
nó trả lời tranh á. mà nó còn trọng tâm
được đúng cái tôi hỏi nhiều lúc mà con
này nó trả lời nó cứ lệch lệch trọng tâm
kiểu gì hiện tại đang đúng bởi vì rõ
ràng nó không hề liên quan đến cá nhân
hóa là đúng thôi chứ mấy cái câu mà tôi
hỏi liên quan cá nhân hóa kiểu kiểu gọi
như là tôi từng nó nhắc nó trước đấy
ngay trên luôn nhá không cần nhí phải mở
cái lịch sử khác ấy nó trả lời kiểu
chẳng liên quan gì cả đấy thế mà nó kêu
cứ khoe contex đến 1 triệu
nhìn từ một PP dep lâu năm. Tôi không
thích từ lâu năm này. Tôi rồi. Thế nên
vừa nãy mình dùng từ có kinh nghiệm.
Lâu năm này nó hơi bị nghe nó kiểu khoe
ấy. Ví dụ nhiều người sẽ c thắc mắc lâu
là bao nhiêu đấy chẳng hạn. Thế nó không
hay.
Thứ ra từ có kinh nghiệm nó cũng thế
thôi nhưng mà chỉ có kinh nghiệm nó gọi
là
cho là cứ từng trải một tí.
Trả lời câu này nó hơi bị
ok cũng được. Đây là hành trình tôi xây
dựng lại mental model đảo sâu và clean
architect. Thực ra là nó nhấn mạnh như
này không hay này.
Java bỏ qua cú pháp tập trưng vào tư duy
hành trình 100 ngày tôi tái cấu trúc
mental. Tôi không thích
model.
Ý tôi là
học tư duy thôi.
Bởi vì từ này từ này tôi không biết nên
tôi cũng không muốn lạm dụng vào.
Lâu lắm không gặp thầy. Xin chào bạn. Dù
bạn bình luận thấy tôi không nhận ra bạn
là chào. Tôi thường tôi nhớ mọi người
qua việc người ta cũng thường nhắn tin
tôi cơ. Trừ khi ông bình luận rất nhiều
thôi. Ừ.
không cần phải nhắc việc
không dạy cứu pháp
này cho nó trả lời được đồng ý tôi rồi
đấy. Nó kiểu nó quen với cái giọng văn
mình rồi. Ấ chắc mình mình ừ cứ cho là
mình thích cái giọng văn nó đi. 100 ngày
Java
hành trình chuyển hướng từ PP chuyển
hướng vẫn không đúng.
hành à chuyển hướng
không đúng vì tôi không bỏ PP, tôi chỉ
học thêm Java thôi.
OP và giải quyết các bài toán thiết kế
hệ thống tối ưu backend chuyên sâu hành
trình rẽ nhán. Nơi mình tập trung nghiên
cứu
cái từ nơi mình tập trung này cái nơi
còn nhấn mạnh từ nơi này này nó nấy cái
khóa học mà mình từng đọc nơi mà bạn sẽ
thành công nơi mà bạn sẽ học được abc xz
ở mình mình không muốn nó là một cái
playlist khóa học
thực ra playlist này tôi ghi là học
Ừ, có khi playlist này tôi sửa lại thành
ghi là
ngày thứ bao nhiêu tôi học một cái gì đó
chứ không phải là mỗi học Java thì mọi
người cứ tưởng là vào đây để học nhở.
nó mang hơi một tí cá nhân hóa hơn là
tôi học hoặc là
sửa lại như nào đấy.
Trực diện và chuyên nghiệp mở rộng nền
tảng từ PP.
Câu này cũng được này. Mở rộng mà đúng
không? Từ mở rộng cũng hay. Tập trung
đào sâu
100 ngày.
Java song hành của PP không đúng.
Mở rộng thì đúng, song hành không đúng.
Kiểu giống như kiểu mình
đang học song song cả PP cả Java không
đúng. Nâng cấp tư duy backend qua 100
ngày học cũng được. Đào sâu về thứ thứ.
tư duy backend qua 100 ngày học Java đảo
sâu về Clean Architect OP và các bài
toán thiết kế tối ưu hệ thống từ góc
nhìn của một lập trình viên PP được
không hề nhấn mạnh việc là mình là người
có kinh nghiệm rồi mình là lâu năm nơi
nơi đây chúng ta vân vân vân không chỉ
nói đi thẳng vào trọng tâm đúng không là
mình nâng cấp dùng từ nâng cấp rất là
hay vì nó ngang với từ mà tôi thích nó
đừ develop mình là developer đúng nhiều
người dịch lập trình viên nhưng thực ra
là develop là kiểu phát triển nâng tầm
nó lên đúng không nâng cấp nó lên đấy
nâng cấp vốn những cái đang có sẵn nghĩa
là mình không vẽ lại bánh xe đúng không
ạ mình thực ra là mình có thể đi code
người khác cũng được không sao mình sẽ
dựa vào những cái người ta đã từng cái
trò phát minh hơi vĩ đại đi từ hơi giật
đau to bối lớn tí nhưng đại khái người
ta viết ra những cái đoạn đấy
mình tái sử dụng lại để mình làm ra được
những cái sản phẩm khác giá trị hơn, tốt
hơn thì đấy là gọi phiên bản nâng cấp
hơn đúng không? Đấy thì từ nâng cấp này
rất là hay. Được tôi sẽ tham khảo cái từ
này.
Đấy đây nó sẽ trả lời cho cái câu của
bạn vừa nãy hỏi. Em lần đầu xem cố anh
học Java theo hướng nào vậy ạ? Thì nó sẽ
theo hướng này em nhá.
Đấy mình sẽ sửa lại. À
Ok.
Chào các bạn.
Đợi tôi tí, tôi đang ngồi chỉnh cái mấy
cái này. Thực ra là mấy ông sẽ thấy là
kiểu ông ấy bị sao ấy, kiểu lúc
livestream thì đáng lẽ phải tập trung
vào dậy hoặc tập trung làm cái gì đó lại
đi ngồi à kiểu làm cái khác. Như thực ra
là tôi cũng không có nhiều thời gian làm
những cái khác kiểu c thử nên thành
trong lúc mà tôi livestream này tôi sẽ
tranh thủ làm thêm một cái gì đó nữa nên
mong mấy ông thông cảm.
rất mong về ông thông cảm đúng không ạ?
Ok.
khóa học này mấy ông không biết mấy ông
thấy chưa?
cái câu thực ra là có nhiều cái bài rất
là dài thì không phải bài nào tôi cũng
đọc hết đâu. Tôi không phải là người
ờ tôi vốn từng là một người rất là kiểu
mọt sách, mọt game mình thích chơi game,
mình đi đọc sách. Nhưng mà không phải là
cái gì rất dài, tôi cũng đọc. Ví dụ là
tôi không đọc chuyện chữ nhiều hay vân
vân. Nhưng mà bài này tôi thể ấn tượng
ngay. Cái đầu tiên nó nhắc đến WeChat.
Tôi luôn khâm phục cái cái ứng dụng
Weat. Nếu các bạn không biết thì nó là
tính như là một cái gọi là siêu ứng dụng
là một Super App đúng không? Tức là sao?
Nghĩa là một cái ứng dụng nó chứa rất
nhiều cái ứng dụng khác ở trong này.
Thì ở đây chứa nhiều ứng dụng khác là
như thế nào?
Tí tại sao ở đây nó không hiển thị là
đang có bao nhiêu người xem nhỉ? Tôi bị
lỗi ở đâu?
thì rõ ràng là ứng dụng Wechat nó tích
hợp rất nhiều và đã có rất nhiều cái a
ứng dụng khác của Việt Nam cũng cố từng
làm tương tự. Ví dụ là hồi trước là Zalo
này à không tôi thấy thằng đầu tiên thì
sẽ là Momo à nếu bây giờ nó vẫn cố làm
tức là sao nó gộp hết trong đấy từ việc
là lúc nào chỉ ví điện tử đúng không ạ
sau về sau tích hợp thêm là thanh toán
những cái thứ khác ngay trên chính nền
tảng của nó mua mọi thứ trên chính nền
tảng của nó xong rồi biến hành gần như
là mạng xã hội cũng có nhá bởi vì bởi vì
mấy ông sẽ không nghĩ nó là mạng xã hội
nhưng mà mạng xã hội nó sẽ chỉ đơn giản
là bao gồm có nhắn tin có nhân được,
bình luận có bình luận được có đăng bài
đăng bài được kết nối với mọi người với
nhau có thì rõ ràng nó tính của mạng xã
hội rồi đấy thì rõ ràng là có. Bình luận
ở đây sẽ là bình luận ở ch những cái bài
đăng ở khi mà mấy ông a tôi thấy là đa
số ấy thì sẽ là ở mấy cái bên a đầu tư
ấy. Tôi mua chứng chứng khoán hay chứng
chứng chỉ quỹ lên đấy thì sẽ có đăng bài
trên đấy nhiều. và mọi người bình luận
trong đấy nhiều hoặc là thực ra có mấy
trò chơi của nó cũng có mấy cái đấy. Đấy
thì siêu ứng dụng ở trên đấy người lag
vãi chưởng. Tôi tôi dùng Android thì ok
có thể bảo tôi là Android đều nên chính
là nó lag nhưng mà tôi
nghĩ là một cái siêu ứng dụng nó không
phải là
à không anh đang muốn à không phải mỗi
chỉ ngồi học muốn chia sẻ thêm gì đó thì
anh tranh thủ ngồi nhắc về cái bài hôm
trước anh đọc tản mạn về chatvity ở đây
thì ở đây đang nhắc đến Weat thì tranh
thủ đấy anh sẽ nói về Momo à thư thực ra
là
cũng hạn chế chê về một cái ứng dụng
Việt đúng không? Mình là người Việt
không biết sợ bị đánh vần quyền hay sợ
gì đó khác không nhưng mà thực sự không
phải chê nữa. Mình đang nói thẳng luôn.
Tôi đã từng gửi cá nhân tôi nhá. Tôi là
một người rất hay gửi phản hồi để góp ý
để mà khuyên các thứ các thứ. Cho dù là
đúng có thể họ code tốt hơn mình hay mọi
thứ. Họ làm mọi thứ kiểu chắc chắn là có
thể chuyên nghiệp hơn. Nhưng mình là
người dùng mà mình vẫn có quyền được
kiểu góp ý các thứ các thứ chứ mình
không phải là kiểu dìm người ta theo
kiểu là người ta làm tốt mình vẫn cố dìm
mình cố m moi ra để tìm không nên tôi đã
nói là kiểu nó có khá nhiều vấn đề.
không? Ý em là con AI á. Con AI thì anh
có set a ru có. Còn con chat DVT á chat
DVT thì anh chẳng có RU gì cả. À hồi
trước là anh có để cái ru là
đừng có nịnh hot nhiều quá.
Cái đấy cũng có thể tính là một cái ru.
anh có dùng cái bộ kit để soạn Ra xong
rồi cũng bảo nó tự chỉnh lại để phù hợp
custom lại để phù hợp với cái project.
Bởi vì mỗi dự án, mỗi project thì nó sẽ
kiểu khác nhau đúng không? Ví dụ là mình
dự án ở trên công ty của tôi là TP thì
sẽ ru sẽ kiểu khác hoặc là à dự án về
FEN thì sẽ ru kiểu khác.
là kiểu kit mà tức là nó tổng hợp của
rất nhiều cái thôi. Em vẫn phải dùng ai
một lần nữa bảo nó đọc cái đống đấy rồi
bảo nó tự sửa lại đống đấy. Anh làm mấy
lần rồi và nó sửa lại để cho nó phù hợp
chứ không thì em ôm vào them vẫn dùng
được nhưng mà nó sẽ kiểu bị chung chung
ấy. Bởi vì n em thích em mở hẳn file đấy
mà đọc vì file đấy bản chất là nó chỉ là
file maxdown, file tex cơ mà. Thì mình
đọc thì em sẽ hình dung được cái mục
đích của nó là gì. Nó cũng chỉ đôi khi
là người ta bảo ru hay là workflow hay
tất cả những thứ khác. bản chất nó chỉ
là những câu prom kiểu nó chạy ngầm để
cho mấy cái thằng kia gọi là thay vì em
viết một câu prom quá dài quá chi tiết
thì bây giờ có một cái ru ở kiểu quy
định là mày phải mình mày phải làm từng
bước từng bước như thế này thế chẳng qua
nó viết prom mẫu sẵn một cái template
cho mình trước thôi. Đấy nghĩa là mỗi
khi mà em chạy prom bình thường của em
nó sẽ đọc qua cái ru này nữa. gọi là
chèn thêm cái đoạn prom đấy vào để mà ra
được một đáp án thôi. Đấy thì rõ ràng là
prom của em mà đủ chất rồi thực ra em
không cần ru lắm mà đôi khi nó còn tốn
token cái việc là nó mà ru mà chung
chung thì giống như các em viết một câu
prom chung chung ấy thì nó sẽ không ra
được kết quả đúng không? Đấy thì kiểu gì
em cũng phải sửa lại cái ru mà nếu mà
không biết sửa tốt nhận không nên dùng
thế thôi.
rất là hay. Nó nó nếu mà hiểu như một
cái ứng dụng nhắn tin thì nó sai. Nó là
hạ tầng.
dùng từ hạ tầng này một từ rất là hay
này. Và cái quan trọng là người dịch này
rất là hay bởi vì nếu mà giả sử mà
tôi chưa xem bằng tiếng Anh nhá nhưng mà
nếu mà dịch đôi khi là nó không dịch ở
hạ tầng hay là dịch một cái từ gì khác
thì có khi là nó không phản ánh rõ được
đúng ý của tác giả. Đấy tôi thấy từ hạ
tầng có một từ rất là hay.
Đây khi một mua một điện chiếc điện
thoại mới ứng dụng đầu tiên cài không
phải là Facebook, không phải là Chrome
mà là Rechat. Bạn không cần cài thêm app
nào khác để sống bình thường.
Chắc là bè làm việc, trả tiền, đặt đồ
ăn.
Tất cả
đều nằm trong Wehat
thông qua một thứ gọi là mini program.
Thực ra vừa rồi vừa rồi tôi vừa thấy à
anh
Dương Dê à đúng không nhở?
Hình như thế anh reviewer ấy, anh ấy
cũng vừa chia sẻ là cái à ứng dụng VN
VNID
mới tích hợp thêm a check in online. Tôi
cảm thấy là ừ có vẻ mọi người đang hướng
đến việc cái app đấy nó sẽ thành kiểu
Nana DQ chat tức là Super App một cái
siêu ứng dụng đúng không? Bởi vì là thấy
là tích hợp trên đấy ngoài tích hợp giấy
tờ xong rồi nói chung là làm liên quan
hành chính thì bây giờ bắt đầu chuyển
qua là mấy cái kiểu là nó vẫn có tí liên
quan đến hành chính, liên quan đến thủ
tục các thứ như vậy về sau sẽ bao gồm
kiểu là
tôi nghĩ là về sau nó sẽ kiểu gì sẽ gần
như là mình sẽ chỉ có cùng lắm là mình
sẽ chỉ vài app ví dụ nhá à tôi để ý gần
đây viện app xanh chẳng hạn
Hợp xanh của Vin đúng không? Đấy tôi
thấy có rất nhiều cái trong đấy rồi. Hồi
trước là còn tách ra tách hắn cái riêng
ra. Ví dụ là xanh phải đặt đồ ăn à không
hồi đấy không biết tách đặt đồ ăn chưa
nhưng mà xanh hồi trước là xanh chỉ là
xanh những cái dịch vụ liên quan đến
xanh thôi nhưng mà bây giờ còn có cả
tích hợp xanh bên Cần Đệ cũng tích hợp.
Nếu mấy các bạn không biết thì nó có
tích hợp luôn cả cái Vinm đấy. Không
biết tôi không có con, chưa có con không
biết là vì sau tích hợp school hay mọi
thứ trong đấy không. Đấy thì mới là nó
tích hợp dần dần dần dần trong một cái
app chung.
Và ít ra là con Vinid tuy là bị có bị
chê việc là đăng nhập vào thỉnh thoảng
có lá
theo kiểu là khó đăng nhập vào ấy chứ
còn đăng nhập vào trong đấy được rồi ấ
thì tôi sẽ dùng mọi mọi cái thứ ít nhất
là mượt nhưng mà vẫn còn ứng dụng của à
nó vẫn là sơ xài, nghĩa là vẫn phải điền
thủ công nhiều cái
và cái việc không thể hiện người dùng
nữa đó
chưa thân thiện nhưng mà ý ra là nó
không lag còn ứng dụng lag như tôi vừa
nãy nói nó nhà mờ ấy lag quên J2 thực ra
cũng gọi là một cái nhóm mọi người
thường hay bảo là đấy nhóm anti của app
M với app Z đúng không
cả hai app cũng đều hướng đến Super App
nhưng tôi cảm thấy là đều khá là tệ
mà vì ngữ cảnh xã hội. Người dùng không
tìm kiếm cái app, không kiểu phát hiện
ra đi, tìm ra đi qua store hay toán. Họ
được bạn bè chia sẻ trực tiếp với nhau
trong nhóm chat, nơi đã có sẵn niềm tin.
Đấy, thậm chí còn trống.
Đây cái này thêm một cái rất là hay này.
Chống recommend mọi người thường hay
dùng từ recommend. Tôi ghét từ này nó sẽ
là chống kiểu giới thiệu chống kiểu
khuyên dùng đúng không? Đấy bình thường
mình sẽ hiển thị lên cái mục là mục là
những ứng dụng bạn có thể sẽ thích đấy.
Mục khuyên dùng hay vân vân vân gì đấy.
Ông này còn bảo thậm chí bài trừ cái đấy
tôi thấy rất là hay.
kiểu nó đi ngược ấy. Đấy bảo là
đây
cái việc à
con đường ngắn nhất, tốt hơn bất kỳ
thuật toán nào. Thay vì mình cứ hiển thị
ra một đống kiểu khuyên dùng vào đấy.
Mọi người cảm thấy dối và mọi người còn
bắt đầu nghi ngờ về nó. Thì đôi khi mọi
người bây giờ cảm thấy là nó giống như
là được mua ấy, kiểu bởi vì mấy cái
khuyên dùng ấy đôi khi là được trả tiền
để được lên đấy mà nên thành ra là nó bị
kiểu giả ấy. Mọi người bây giờ không
quan tâm đâu. Mọi người bị dị kiểu
cứ cho là kiểu kỳ thị ngầm. À từ đúng nó
là gì nhở?
Mọi người bị à à
b trừ à không đúng.
Mọi người bị ác cảm. Đúng rồi. Bị
[tiếng cười] ác cả mấy cái kiểu
khuyên dùng đấy. Đặc biệt là cứ có gắn
chữ là đã được tài trợ, đã được quảng
cáo thôi. Xem bởi vì rõ ràng lúc đấy nó
họ sẽ nghĩ ngay luôn là mình là
mình đang được mua bán, mình đang được
trao đổi, mình đang được mời hàng mình
không thích kiểu đấy. Mình thích thực sự
là một cái ứng dụng mọi người khuyên
dùng nó đủ tốt chứ không phải là thằng
thằng này trả tiền để được kiểu gợi ý
cho mình.
nhân hóa thì càng tốt nữa đúng không?
Và quay lại Open AI.
Open AI gần đây tung ra những cái gọi là
app nằm trong trình cái Open AI. Đấy.
nó khác nó không khác gì với Meta hay
Google trước đây. Đấy. Open AI không có
mối quan hệ giữa người với người mà chỉ
người với công cụ đúng không ạ?
chat thì kéo được cả hệ sinh thái vào
trong vì nó là nghĩ ra người với người
với nhau. Còn chapit chỉ có người với ai
đấy.
gần đây là chatt còn bắt đầu có thể sẽ
kiểu nhúng cả quảng cáo ở trong này.
Thậm chí ở phía sau là nó là kiểu quảng
cáo, kiểu nó gợi ý là các bạn sản phẩm
hay các thứ thứ như nào vân vân. Thì rõ
ràng là tôi thấy là nó sẽ
có thể người dùng sẽ e chừng nó hơn khi
mà thấy nó hiểu mình quá và gợi ý những
cái thứ. Cứ cho là tốn tiền đi đúng
không? Đấy mình sẽ hơi sợ nó. Lúc đầu
đang nói chuyện này thì mình thấy hay
mình cảm thấy là ừ nó đang cá nhân hóa
tốt nó đang đồng cảm với mình. Mình
thích nó nghe nó chứ về sau lại cảm thấy
nó có cái gì đang thao túng mình thì
mình sẽ không thích nó nữa. Mình sẽ có
tí kìa dè chừng hơn.
tại. Phải học cách nói chuyện với nó.
Phải đoán xem prom thế nào cho đúng.
phải chỉnh câu chữ chỉnh đi này lại. Đôi
khi kết quả đúng nhưng mất quá nhiều
công sức thì tới đó. Cái này thì tôi
không chắc lắm. Tôi không nghĩ ở việc là
nói chuyện với một con AI ít nhất là về
chatt còn những thả khác thì tôi cảm
thấy vẫn hơi ức chế thật.
Thì tôi thấy là không khó để mà nói
chuyện với nó. Mấy ông thấy không? Mấy
ông có thấy khó khi nói chuyện với CHVT
không? Cảm thấy không? Dễ mà. Tôi thấy
khó hơn nếu mà cùng cái câu đấy nói với
thằng Gemini thì tôi không chắc
số đông đúng không? Mình đôi khi là mình
à ra lệnh hồi đầu nói chuyện thì mình sẽ
không biết ra lệnh, mình không viết viết
khái niệm prom n tôi nghĩ là về sau đủ
tốt. Kiểu bây giờ nói thẳng luôn là bây
giờ khi mà mình đang nói chuyện hàng
ngày với nó, nó vẫn đang học từ mình nên
thành ra là về sau nó sẽ dần dần là
chúng ta sẽ không cần phải prom chuyên
nghiệp nữa. nó vẫn hiểu được tất cả mọi
người đang nói chuyện theo phong cách
như thế nào và mọi người nói này bản
chất là mọi người đang muốn gì đấy kiểu
thế lúc đấy không cần prom quá xịn nữa
cũng được thế nên là cái thời gian đầu
ấy thời gian đầu ấy ai mới nổ mình không
biết có ngành nghề gì hot không là ngành
nghề này bây giờ vẫn hot à không
lúc thời gian đầu là có tận hai ngành
hot cơ còn bây giờ chỉ có một ngày hot
thôi nhá thời gian đầu có một ngành hot
đó ngành ngành là ngành prom
nghĩa là hướng dẫn các bạn ạ prom sao
cho chuột và
được cái prom các bạn nhập vào. Còn bây
giờ thì sẽ chỉ còn một ngành hot thôi.
Đó là ngành kiểu vẫn hướng dẫn các bạn
dùng AI nhưng không thiên về việc là mỗi
prom chuẩn nữa. Đương nhiên là có có
nhắc đến prom chuẩn nhá nhưng mà sẽ nhắc
nhiều việc là AI có thể làm được gì và
các bạn nên dùng AI mọi thứ vân vân như
thế nào đấy có bây giờ gần đây đẻ thêm
cái vụ skin các thứ thứ kia nữa thôi
đúng không như skin đấy cả prom thôi đấy
nhưng mà còn cái người viết prom để mà
trên change cho ai nó thực sự là vốn là
công công việc lâu rồi chứ không phải
gần đây mới nổi nữa gần đây là chẳng qua
ai nó phụ phổ biến nên nên là mọi người
cảm thấy là muốn kiểu phomo đi. Cứ cho
vào mọi người bị kiểu sợ là mình sẽ bị
thậu, sợ mình bị lỗi thời nên là mình sẽ
phải học một cái gì đó phải biết viết
prom chuẩn. Không theo mình nghĩ là một
con LL
LM bây giờ đã học được nhiều và đủ mạnh
để mà các bạn viết prom bình thường cũng
hiểu được. Còn nếu mà viết prom bình
thường mà không hiểu được, nói chuyện
bình thường mà không hiểu được thì chỉ
đơn giản là con AI đều. Nên là hôm trước
có người bảo với tôi là kìa ông chưa đủ,
chắc là ông chưa đủ trình để nói chuyện
với con Jamin rồi. Tôi cảm thấy kìa. Tại
sao bây giờ nói chuyện
với một con AI thông minh
thì người dùng thực ra không cần thông
minh lắm. Còn nếu mà mình phải rất thông
minh để nói chuyện với nó thì chứng tỏ
là con đấy đang có vấn đề. Ông hiểu gì
tôi không?
Bởi vì đúng là nếu phải người thông minh
thì nên mới nói chuyện được người thông
minh đúng không? Nhưng mà nếu nó cực kỳ
thông minh ấy và EQ nu đủ cao, ví dụ giả
sử ông nói chuyện ngoài đời đi thế là dễ
hiểu hơn nhá.
Ông có thể nghĩ là tôi không đủ thông
binh để nói chuyện với ông. Vì vì ông
rất thông minh. Đấy chẳng hạn. Thế nhưng
mà nếu thế ông nói thế chỉ đang nói so
sánh về IQ đấy. Còn nếu về EQ giả sử ông
đủ thông minh và EQ ông đủ cao ấy thì
ông nói chuyện với bất kỳ ai cũng được.
Đấy những người EQ cao thì người ta lại
nói chuyện được với bất kỳ ai. Kể cả dù
người ta nói chuyện với người EQ hay
thấp hơn mình họ vẫn nói chuyện được.
Đấy thì tức là sao? Nghĩa là nó liên
quan việc là thông minh ở đấy dựa trên
yếu tố nào. Nếu mà giả sử là thông minh
chỉ nói chuyện được với người thông minh
ấy thì thì con AI kia nó không phù hợp
cho số đông. Đấy. Còn nếu mà AI đã muốn
làm AI phổ thông thì rõ ràng phải ai
cũng có thể ra lệnh nó, ai cũng có thể
nói chuyện được với nó.
Đấy có thể nói chuyện giả sử là người
không thông minh thì nói chuyện với nó
ra prom nó không chuẩn. Ok, nó có thể ra
đáp án không chuẩn nhưng nghĩ ra nó vẫn
nói chuyện được nhá. Còn đây mà kiểu
mình ra prom cho nó xong rồi nó lại trả
lời hoàn toàn khác hoặc nó có thể thậm
chí bảo lại là mày phải viết prom chuẩn
hơn hay gì gì đó thì tự nhiên là khiến
người dùng phải suy nghĩ. Và là một trền
lập trình viên tôi vẫn nhớ cái câu đó là
một ứng dụng mà khiến người dùng phải
nghĩ để sử dụng. Thì đây là ứng dụng tồi
đấy.
Mình phải làm ứng dụng sao cho mà
gọi là người dùng càng bớt nghĩ thì túi
tiền của mình càng dùng rỉnh. À tôi nhớ
cái câu đại ý nó ở đấy. Tôi không nhớ
câu ấy chính xác là gì.
này app inap là đóng gói intem bắt người
dùng diễn đạt
khả năng sử dụng thực tế trong es cụ thể
cập vào một động cơ rất mạnh nhưng không
vô lăng, không bảng điều khiển. App
chính là UI API cho hệ thống đó. đều đặc
biệt. Nếu
tôi hiểu đoạn này của bạn ấy nói của à
không phải bạn đấy của ông ông ấy nói
đây giống như vừa nãy tôi nói prom kém
output kém người dùng nghĩ AI sâu đúng
nó không phải chúng ta không thể khen AI
thông minh thế nào nhưng mà rõ ràng là
AI có đủ thông minh để hiểu mình đâu thì
rõ ràng đây vẫn là một AI tồi thôi ai
sinh ra được phục vụ mình chứ không phải
là mình đi AI sinh ra rồi mình còn phải
cố hiểu nó để mà đáp ứng được nhu cầu
của mình.
Đương nhiên là ông nào mà càng hiểu được
AI, cơ chế hoạt động AI và càng biết tận
dụng AI như thế nào để tốt cho cuộc sống
hay tốt cho công việc thì đúng thế là
rất là tốt.
Như tôi đang nói là cái AI mà muốn phổ
thông muốn chung thì đó rằng là AI đấy
phải làm cho mà mọi người dùng từ tất cả
thì nó hơi khó nhưng chị ạ số đông dùng
được dùng được nhá không cần ấy dùng một
cách kiểu quá xịn nhá
bây giờ thì mọi người đang thiên hướng
là muốn dùng AI rất là xịn cơ
bao người muốn vai code này muốn làm ra
ứng dụng các thứ thứ hôm trước Rất nhiều
người đăng bài hỏi ra là kìa em mới học
em dùng AI để có thể làm ra được trong
web không?
khác mất rồi.
Ok, chắc là ông này bàn sâu một tí về kỹ
thuật mình. Cái cái trên thì đang rất là
hay, đang rất là trều tượng. Ok. Tôi
thấy sâu về kỹ thuật này tôi cảm thấy
thôi bỏ qua. Ok. Đợi tôi tí tôi đóng cái
máy giặt cho đỡ ôn à.
tự nhiên vừa rồi chưa học mình đã nói
chuyện tận 50 phút mà tôi lại nhớ đến
cái phim hôm qua tôi vừa xem nữa. Phim
hôm qua tôi vừa xem nó về trinh thám
nhưng mà nó nói rất nhiều phải đến
cứ cho một nửa bộ phim.
là nói và hùng hùng điện nhiều đấy. Có
khi tôi bị lây mất rồi.
Thông cảm
thôi mình sẽ quay lại học đi.
Hôm nay thực ra hôm nay tôi cũng chưa
biết được mình sẽ học gì đâu. À dựa theo
bậy tí tôi xem lịch sử đã.
dựa vào hôm trước
hôm trước là mình á
tập thôi.
Mình sẽ
sửa vào
à thật cả mình ghi hết ở trên trước rồi.
Tôi nghĩ là tôi sẽ chỉnh ngắn gọn là
soạn cho tôi bài
nửa Việt mà không sao.
nói thật ra hôm qua mấy cái bài Hùng
viện đấy nó bị nặng rất nặng về à kiểu
có tí mang tiếng ở phim a trinh thám
nhưng mà nhắc đến cả tôn giáo có đề cập
cả tôn giáo tín ngưỡng ở trong đấy nên
phim đấy nó sẽ khá là nặng. May là hôm
qua tôi không buồn ngủ lắm.
Hôm nay có hơi hơi hơi một tí buồn ngủ
vì
hôm nay đi cả ngày ngủ ít.
Xem à
culation enculation.
Encapsulation. Tôi chưa biết từ này bây
giờ. Để tôi sẽ
translate đi.
>> Encapsulation.
Ừ tôi sẽ phải nhắt ở đây ru
à
một cái file ở đây luôn mấy ông nhỉ à
đâu chẳng cần mình sẽ tạo
fileu ở đây luôn cho mấy ông để mấy ông
biết cách pu nhá
ờ customize này
global này cái này là tôi dùng cái
Contex 7 để mà tự động soạn các thứ các
thứ.
Hả? Ô P là sao em?
Circle đâu. Phim hôm qua nó là cái
gì nhở?
Phim qua trinh thám mà nó là phim knife
Out
là kẻ đâm lén dịch tiếng Việt ra là thế
à tên người ta để là thế cái này đặt tên
Ru là
Ru cứ đặt tên là Ru thôi nhở đơn giản
thôi. Đây
tôi để tiếng Việt ch được không sao
không tự
ờ tạo file class
đây
cứ tạm thầy thế trước đã tải lại Ơ
biết rồi mà nhỉ.
Đây có một agent này.
file đặt tên như thế này không ổn.
Dog đi.
vãi chưởng. Cái này còn không được.
nhận được trong này đấy.
xn đâu có ảnh hưởng đâu nhỉ?
xong rồi tôi phải ấn nút xếp lại nó vào
đây. Ok thầy có nhiều vấn đề thật.
Tại hiểu tại sao không nên dùng public
field. Ừ cái này tôi cũng mường tượng ra
được.
Dùng getter setter đúng truy cập private
default public protect
default á. Default sẽ là như nào nhỉ?
Không khai báo mặc định nó sẽ là default
đúng không? Tôi tôi không khai báo ở
trong PP tôi toàn thấy nó giống biến
thành plic. Không biết là nó trong này
nó sẽ thế không.
cũng sửa được đúng không? Mình cập nhật
cái này xong rồi in ra đấy. Lỗi không
thể truy cập vào đấy các thứ thứ đấy.
Khai báo cụ thể private m cái gì gì đó
public là như này đây khởi tạo đúng
không? có thể get set này không có set
nếu mà muốn đổi thì phải đi qua một cái
hàm nào đó đúng không? Đi qua một cái
method nào đó và trong này nó sẽ có một
cái gọi là điều kiện cho nó để mình xét
thô không xét trực tiếp được đúng không?
từ tiền qua method nào đó rút tiền qua
mất nào đó có kiểm tra hợp lý hơn đấy
xong rồi lấy ra thử phá hoại khử gửi
tiền âm bị chặn
được
uầy cái này rất là ngắn gọn nhưng mà nó
đã thể hiện được phần nào nhưng
nó không nhắc đến default nhỉ đâu
default của tôi đâu
và
cả nhắc tới
các mức truy cập nữa.
nay không? Không, bài hôm nay ngắn thế
rồi đấy.
Trăm ngày, mỗi ngày học chục dòng
tôi cảm thấy mini map này tôi trong dụng
có để làm gì không?
mình xóa này đi thì sẽ thành default
thôi chứ quan trọng là
default này mặc định là gì? Mặc định nó
sẽ là public mà đúng không? Hay nó có
thêm một cái quy ước một cái điều kiện
nào nữa?
nó tự động chạy file class
file class. Thế tớt rồi
nó vẫn tạo file class.
Cái cái này tôi nghĩ là cái cái này cái
dở của trong antiravity.
Tôi không nghĩ là thằng khác đã bị dính
cái này. Ít nhất là tôi dùng cái insert
không bị dính. Đó khi mình ghi ru rồi ấy
nó sẽ tuân theo cái ru này thật chứ
không phải là rõ ràng mình để ở đây ru
mấy ông thấy vừa nãy có set ru đúng
không chả phải để tiếng anh không nghĩ
là do tiếng anh tiếng Việt đâu. Bọn này
đã là AI LM thì nó không phân biệt tiếng
Anh tiếng Việt. Đây đã để away on rồi
nhá.
Không đúng không?
không?
Tôi không biết cái này anh em nào trả
lời cho ông người với.
Default chỉ trong class này riêng tư
nhất à đâu private đây chỉ trong pack
này mặc định nếu không biết gì.
À bây giờ tôi biết khái niệm default này
kiểu như này đấy. Pit à kit thì chắc là
mình cũng chả bao giờ dùng trong cái
packit nên thành ra là kiểu
nó trong cái project này đúng không?
đang hiểu là tạo ra một class nó dạng
data ấy.
nhỉ? Đúng không?
đâ
mục này đúng không
thư mục vậc ngoài tính là một cái vit
đúng
rồi
trong packet này class con kế thừa khác.
Ok
anh anh có nhớ cái vụ vụ này rồi à? Ừ.
Hồi trước học Java uầy, phải nhắc lại
nhớ cái thời học Java thì mới nhớ cái
mấy cái khái niệm này.
Truy cập thoải mái.
thứ truy cập được vì cùng PIT.
Lỗ ngay né bỏ comment xem
cũng dễ hiểu. Ok. Thế các bài hôm nay sẽ
chỉ ngắn này thôi. Không biết mấy ông có
cảm thấy kiểu cần bổ sung thêm gì thì cứ
nói nhá.
Tôi sẽ cập nhật đọc. Cập nhật đâu cho
tôi
ra tiếp một bài nữa.
À không phải một bài nữa mà kiểu một cái
ảnh nữa. Còn không bài hôm nay sẽ chỉ
ngắn thế thôi ấy. Ui, mình nói chuyện
kiểu 50 phút xong rồi học trong 10 phút.
cái thở ở trên Discord của tôi rồi đúng
không?
nhiêu ông vào đấy. Bình luận chat thì ít
mấy ông vào nhiều thế.
Đúng rồi, kênh tôi bắt đầu đang đề xuất
cho người mới là nhiều chứ người cũ có
vẻ là thế người cũ vẫn xem như nói là
người cũ vào chat ở đây còn là người mới
thì chỉ vào đã xem thôi cũng không thấy
chat mấy.
hay phết
kiểu dạng là như cảnh sát sát đúng
không?
Hình sát này cầm cái cái này batong à
không phải baong cái này gọi là gì à cui
à kiểu cái thế xong rồi lá chắn này bảo
vệ này u hay nhở lúc nhìn đầu tôi cứ
tưởng giống như cái khóa cơ nhưng cái
này chắc là mũ
được nhỉ
hacker gán
này ui cái này dễ hiểu ấy cần thêm cái
khác không nhỉ
Cái này cũng hay này. Cái vừa rồi cũng
hay cơ. Tận hai cái hay chuẩn là nó sẽ
phải có hai ảnh thì hợp lý
nhở.
Không thấy cái vừa rồi hay đúng không?
cũng không nhìn thấy nữa rồi.
Đây đây đây cái này này. Đấy
nào.
Cái này cũng hay
nhắc đến bảo vệ có cái này nhắc đến tính
đóng gói
rất hợp lý mà đúng không?
để có hai ảnh được.
ấn nhầm rồi lại chưa? Hình như là bấm
này nó vẫn ra được cái cũ phải.
Đây đây đây.
để cả hai nhá. Ừ.
sẽ a
bngngng.
Chúng ta sẽ có rất nhiều ảnh để dễ hình
dung. Ui
cái chữ màu trắng thì phải không nhìn
được cái gì cả.
Xem à
này thôi.
Ok.
Hôm nay không thì sẽ chỉ học đến thế này
thôi đấy. Mấy ông sẽ thấy là ừ nó có thể
rất là ngắn nhưng mà tôi sẽ không dạy à
tôi không học quá nhiều trong một ngày
đâu. Kiểu mỗi ngày sẽ chỉ tí một tí một
như này. Mà cái này tính a ngắn mà đúng
không? hay là chắc là do tôi dùng cái
con AI tạo ra 100 ngày nó hơi bị kiểu
nhiều kiểu nó dài dàn trải quá nên thành
ra là kiểu ngày 7 chắc là người ta chỉ
cho ngần này kiến thức thôi tôi không
biết
tổng hợp
ừ tổng hợp kiến thức
6 đây đây 6 ngày đi.
À đây có cho chuyên nghiệp nhỉ? À không
nhưng mà mình để trong a playlist là
ngày rồi. 6 ngày đã học.
Ok.
Cái này mình sẽ đặt tên là
bình thường sẽ để code lên kiểu như này
này.
đây. Bó
ừ thật ra là cái này chẳng có gì thắc
mắc cả.
Không sao, có gì mình sẽ nói chuyện vào
ngày mai khi mà có thêm nhiều thứ thắc
mắc hoặc là giải đáp thêm sau. Còn không
thì chào mấy ông nhá. Một ngày học một
tiếng thôi. Xin chào mấy ông nhá. Vai